hey everyone it's Mike and welcome to
this presentation on the order flows
Delta scalper today is recording this on
Sunday it's July 8th and I'm gonna talk
about what happened in the markets on
July 6th on Friday the non-farm payroll
day so before I begin the brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures train
contain substantial risk is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capitalism money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one to enhance the security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading in only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider training
past performance is not necessary
indicative of future results tools they
use in this presentation are the Delta
scalper and the order flows trader
mostly the Delta scalper this
presentation is made for the Delta
scalper users or potential users now
just really quick the settings I'll go
through the settings if you're not
familiar with them in this case I'm
using a look back 25 negative Delta
strength of two positive Delta strength
of two the signal box height that's this
is set to two the opacity is set to 25
the width how long it is is set to 15
and the signal mark displacement is
where the upper and down triangle
appears to price levels off that's the
two and I'm gonna have it signal only on
higher highs or lower those and this
other stuff you don't need to worry
about a data series set up on each tick
calculates on each tick the labels dealt
the scalper obviously maximum bars look
back to 56 visual this stuff you don't
need to worry about again you know if
you have some other indicators that you
know from someone else and you know
maybe the colors clash or something like
you know maybe you got them as the same
colors you can adjust it in here under
the plot so you could change the color
to whatever you want I like royal blue
you can change it I have it set the
solid as a dash dial
plot style trying to go up you know you
can do all sorts of different things
triangle up for a Buy or when it's the
negative Delta triangle down for a sell
I try to keep buys in the blue colors
and sells sort of the red pinkish tones
the reason why I went with magenta on
this is because I've got a few other
things that I that I run that is also
that are also red so you know I just
want conflicting I'm so used to it as
being magenta and royal blue already
that my eyes are trained for it so first
you know start off in the buttons and I
can I'm rain this on a normal bar chart
at the moment and you know to show you
for Friday on the buns how it how it
looked
this was Thursday here again you know
I'm people say well you're not showing
Thursday because it sucked well you know
on Thursday you had this little trade
here that was winter this little trade
there you know by I sort of went nowhere
I and you know you had a nice sell here
on Thursday morning you know for the 160
to 42 area down town into the 14 area
nice 30 point winner so even though you
had these little breakeven trades in
here maybe a little scratch and you know
a small profit here you know you had
your 30 point winner there but really
what really what I want to show you is
Friday so we started off Friday again
you know yeah I can take trade two
minutes before the close on Thursday but
anyway Friday you know you started off a
nice little pop up here nice nice little
trade here a little bit later another
nice trade coming in here this one just
sort of went nowhere but now you know
you're coming up on the non-farm payroll
numbers and yeah I don't care you know
if you have the greatest trading system
in the world you can't be involved
during the number you know I mean unless
you're trading the number you know
you're not an economist you're a trader
you trade based on prices not you know
economic predictions now you know that's
just something I learned very early on
you know I could see how you know back
on the days when I was on the floor you
know really the the only time the phone
the only phones that were ringing were
the retail brokers phones that were
ringing you know the other big traders
were sitting on the sidelines waiting
for the number to come out in the market
to digest it you know obviously the
other traders the locals in the pit were
active because you know they're they're
making the markets and and making their
money but you know you're not going to
take a trade boom right when the number
comes out and you know and get a
knee-jerk reaction I don't you know I
see some people that say oh I like to
trade the numbers well yeah you know
when you guess right it goes in your
goes in your favor
but when you guess wrong it'll go
against you extremely fast and you know
by the time you get out the markets
really moved quite a lot so you know
early on before the numbers came out you
had plenty you got a couple
opportunities couple nice opportunities
here early on you know you could have
even bought it on the pullback in here
and took a nice ride up you know this is
nice 15 20 ticks right there another
opportunity here for another 15 you know
20 ticks you know you're getting along
at 162 you know 62 63 64 all the way up
into you know here's 70 and then you
know another push up into close to 80
and that's well before the number comes
out you know I mean you could have taken
one of those trades and you know in the
buns it's it's 10 euros a tick then you
know you don't have to worry about what
the numbers going to do and try to play
catch up the rest of the day
later in the day this is around the cash
closed in the buns and yeah you had
trade that failed then came right back
with a nice little little winning trade
that would have covered your losses on
that previous trade and your going into
you know evening time in Germany already
here is noon time Chicago time and did
this trade work out yeah it worked out
but it's only you only talking a couple
of ticks here and obviously I don't
think you won't look into trick it pick
any sort of trade and interest rate on a
Friday afternoon at 2 o'clock Chicago
time cash markets are closed around the
world
so next market will look at will look at
Nasdaq and Nasdaq again this is a
1-minute chart as well let's give it a
second here to get the signals here so
you know just walk it back again yo
Nasdaq you know when you're looking at
stocks I find it best to especially when
you're dealing with Delta this
to the main training session yeah you
can trade it you know early morning you
know six o'clock is okay actually most
like ESPYs well you you pretty much
trade those around the clock but I
prefer to trade them from European hours
until until the US close rather than
mess around in the Asian hours you know
just the liquidity isn't there I mean
you do get liquidy that picks up during
the Japan hours but again you know Japan
goes on lunch for an hour then things
die down so it's a bit it's a bit here
and there is the only way I'd put it but
again you know if you're trading Nasdaq
in the middle of the night when you're
dealing with something like Delta
alright you want something that's gonna
give you some solid Delta numbers now
just really quick let's look on this is
a one-minute chart I'll just take a look
at you know the sort of volume so you're
looking at at the middle of the night
here you know you're dealing with
volumes you know when it gets to about
eleven o'clock you know forty of
contracts 90 58 79 61 15 that's a lot
for that time you know 45 82 11 this is
a 1-minute chart you know so you're
getting some periods in here with with
very very illiquid markets you know
seven contracts traded 13 contracts
traded and you know it's it's not gonna
really give you much information to
trade off of you know I mean when you're
talking with a bar with seven contracts
traded over a minute
you know you can't make a good trading
decision based off of that and then you
know you got a bar here as goes you know
13 lot seven lots 19 lots and 50 to 55
36 it starts to pick up
but then it dies down again you know
I've tried after midnight you got ninety
seven 58 you know 60 you know really
what you want when you're dealing with
any type of volume analysis or Delta
analysis is you want solid bars of
volume and for me I just find it picks
up around 2:00 a.m. when the European
cash markets open up and you know you
start getting consistently better
numbers I feel you know here you're
looking at 231 you know now you're
getting over a hundred regularly 294 273
100 143 1
50 to 300 300 you know 98 100 117 it's
it's averaging better numbers I mean you
do get some periods in here 44 - 45 90
but nowhere near what you're gonna get
during the us day session obviously once
the cache opens you know a thousand you
know one-minute period 1800 813 hundred
eleven hundred you know nine hundred I
just find it I wanna say it gives you
true or truer readings but you know like
I said you know anytime you're dealing
with volume analysis and especially
Delta analysis you you you want solid
numbers and I just find during the cache
hours is the most liquid you know is
going to give you more indication true
or indications of what's happening in
the market you know that said I'm not
gonna say well it's 6:00 a.m. he could
have taken this trade no you know I mean
it was it a winner yeah I was a winner a
small one but again I'm not really
looking to trade Nasdaq it at 6:00 in
the morning so anyway when you get here
into the you know eleven o'clock 11:30
yeah the sell here yeah I would have
stopped you out again it's when you're
dealing with this
Nasdaq all right you know that this is a
market that can move a lot right and so
say you're getting short somewhere in
here call it 72 20 and it trades up to
you know twenty three you know three
points that that's plenty of risk
already because you know you take your
loss you can you're getting short here
twenty you know maybe get stopped out at
20 or 22 okay you wait for the next
trade here you know it's giving you the
trade you know somewhere in here so
you're getting along so you getting
light say you missed this bar in the
entry getting lighting in here at 16 you
know 16 all the way up to I'm not gonna
say you are sold it up here you know
maybe up to here you know 28 somewhere
in here you know 16 oh that's that's 12
point so you lost to here but you got 16
there you know that that's what you like
to see as a trader
what else
well look at the euro currency I don't
think there are any signals in the euro
currency on Friday on the 1-minute chart
let me just take a look well
there's this one here at 3:00 in the
afternoon but again you I doubt you'd be
looking to take a trade at 3:00 in the
afternoon on Friday again right ahead of
the number yeah it gives you a sell
signal again you know this is what you
got to deal with right and so I talked
about nice talk about not trading at the
number you know at some point you got to
shut it off because if you're gonna take
a trade here at 725 726 Holley you hold
it for two minutes
a minute yeah you can take a chance but
definitely you want to be off before the
number yes it can go in your way like
here how it moved from 75 all the way up
to you know 118 20 okay it could have
very easily sold off as well but that's
the chance you take you mean you're not
an economist and you don't know what the
job numbers are going to be although
under Trump and job numbers have been
very good but um again you know you're
analyzing what you've seen in the market
and a very important piece of
macroeconomic data is about to come out
that's going to change everyone's views
so there's really no point no need to
stay in the market during that time
period you know just you know get out if
you know if you want you can get back in
later but you know if you know if you
say you had to stop in here okay you put
your stop so you got short okay starts
going anyway market picks up you can say
you got a stop right here at 117 90 okay
maybe you're getting filled you know
between 90 and 95 but chances are it's
moving so fast there's not much
liquidity in there to fill your stop is
by some other stops in there you by
getting stopped out up here around 118
even so you know is it worth it you know
that's the decision you have to make me
personally I just know how the market
reacts and it's just not worth it to me
to be trading around that numbers now
people say oh you're stupid you know you
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about Mike you know listen I've been
trade in these markets since before
there was a euro currency since when it
was a toy truck that's when I started on
the floor there's one last the markets
that I followed was the deutsche mark in
a Swiss franc that was where
work in that and those currency pits so
you know I know what happens when the
numbers come out and I know it's just
not worth the effort and and the
heartache for the times that it goes
against you in trading now you know I'm
curious I haven't looked at the eight
range chart on some of these markets
I just haven't had a chance but again
you know this I showed you minute based
charts now I'm going to take a look at
range based charts here see if there's
any signals no no signals on Friday in
the euro currency there was a signal
Thursday you know it just sort of
chopped down yeah now let's take a look
again at those same markets I just
looked at Nasdaq anything
okay well Nasdaq again since the will go
back to the cash open yeah go back
further so you see nothing going on here
so on the cash opened eight thirty here
this is it eight this is a thirty you
get a cell here stopped you out okay
it's not the end of the world
get another cell over in here Hill from
the 55 area you know hit 45 you know
then just sort of bounced around bounced
around bounced around later you know
didn't catch this big move people say
well you know you missed that big move
well you know did this reads Delta it
reads what's happening in the market
maybe there wasn't anything in that
Delta at that time to give a legitimate
signal especially on when the setting is
set to two and two
you know I have this one again set at
Delta intensity of two it was set at one
there may be a signal there but I'm
talking about setting up two and two and
you get another nice buy signal in here
you know from the 1618 level all the way
up into the 30s well 28 30s got a little
cell here right on the cash closed you
know when you're trading on the cash
closed and equities you tend to get big
surges in volume it's probably the most
volume goes through on the cash closed
more so than then the cash opened
because you know that's where people are
trying to peg their closing to as far as
you know orders go like for the hedge
funds they like to you know target cash
close and they're not gonna use the
futures closed closed futures just close
period you know it's like okay it's it's
four o'clock boom we can we closed for
the day um and wherever the last print
was that's where the last print was but
you know that the big funds you know
they're always targeting cash close the
cash closed level because usually the
working equities the underlying against
the futures as well so that's why you
tend to see a lot of volume going
through like I said the heaviest volume
tends to go through on the cash closed
for the day so you know would you have
you had you know one little loser here a
decent winner here another decent winner
here this one again it's this on the
cash close you know can you take it of
course you can take it but yeah you can
see the churn that's going through here
on the cash closed we were just trading
me 20 28 and 30 for the next couple of
minutes you know so that Basti would
have got a couple tick a couple points
out of it you know at worst you would
have scratched it but you had two great
trading opportunities during the day in
the Nasdaq I I didn't look at the buns
whoops well buns I look at a four range
chart anyway and not an eight range
chart buns again this was Thursday here
this trade didn't work out but then boom
right on the open you had a nice little
trade here this one again it just sort
of it went down immediately into your
favor and it sort of rally back up and
then just sort of hung around going into
the number this is what time is this
this is six-five just before six o'clock
that you get the sell signal you know
it's a little early enough but again you
know if you you're gonna hold it you got
to realize how long you gonna hold it to
you could hold it for an hour and gotten
out you know by seven for just a couple
ticks now you got to realize especially
interest rates which are highly
sensitive to jobs numbers you know
leading up to the unemployment number
it's going to be quiet and you can see
how that would that was here if you
expand this up
you know it's just sort of bouncing
around this is six o'clock here and
basically you're trading between you
know what is that 74 and you know 79 so
basically a 5 tick range until until the
job numbers come out and then we start
trading lower then we pop back up and go
sideways and do what we did so you know
that's the that's the Delta scalper
basically in a nutshell I didn't really
show you any order flow chart other than
that one Nasdaq chart I don't think I
have it on this chart here I don't have
it on this chart either I got it on some
of these I could put it on here give me
a sec let me just go over here let's add
it on here is an indicator just they can
see again you don't stick it through
installing it here so I'll sit to look
back to 25 this was set to 2 and 2 to 2
the opacity said 25 this one I had set
to 15 and that was it that's all you got
to change really I can you don't even
have to change it to default 7 1 and 1
you could use that as well but if you
want to be a bit more what's the word a
bit more tighter stronger I hate to use
those words but um you can so you know
just give it a second here so I remember
it was where were we here just after the
cash open was okay just give it a second
here come in
I see where it was here Nasdaq oh you
know what I was looking at a one minute
Church good a second here see if it's
come off yet so this is the one minute
chart chair can't remember where it was
here in the one minute so you can see
here this is that one that didn't work
out just sorta went sideways on you
he got yourself or to see it hanging
around here before it finally worked out
but or it was the other so here was your
by here you can see how it's just coming
down even if you're watching the Delta
you could sort of get a sense get in a
nice sense of what's happening you got
some negative Delta's and you're
starting to get some nice positive Delta
builds up build up here even here if you
reading the order flow you know you've
seen a couple nice things happening
right around that Delta scalper signal
right you got this prominent point of
control here right here this blue one
but then here you got multiple
imbalances appearing so I think you're
seeing some nice things here you're
seeing even here he's won a Delta f1
this here you got a delta minus one but
you know even this whole stretch in here
it's all nice positive Delta's that's
encouraging
especially after you you've got this
nice little sell off from the 70 222
area you know sawed off ten points down
to 72 12 then you're seeing buyers
starting to come in here that that's
nice and encouraging you know then the
market works its way back up you know
let's see how it looked on that that was
that a range chart
sorry there that's money mm-hmm drink so
here you can see how it was on the cache
close you see how the volume is really
um you know it getting get nice and
strong you know a thousand two hundred
and these you know this isn't this is
it's a range based chart so you can see
how the volume is you're talking 15
seconds of training a thousand two
hundred over the next one second five
hundred over the next nine seconds one
thousand so you see going into the cache
close these are the cache close orders
coming in you know if you're getting
short you know maybe it's somewhere in
here seventy-two thirty and a half
thirty-one maybe or even late here a
thirty you get a little move down you
know over the next you talk in thirty
seconds but you know you when you're
dealing with range based charts it's not
time-based so you know the volumes will
be a bit different then say any some
bars with heavy volume some bars with
light or volume let's go back to that
one by I was there earlier let's see
what we got going on here so you can see
how this is even nice as I can see how
this Delta is on the way down - 120 - 77
- 21-17 right on the swing low starts
turning up 131 positive 8310 102 but you
can see here how the selling is getting
weaker and then boom hit that low the
aggressive buyers came in and what was
interesting is even if you're watching
the max delta min Delta right max delta
tells you how the most positive the
Delta was in the bar min Delta Tozzi the
most negative it was in the bar even if
you're comparing that okay let me get
this crosshairs thing off here it's pain
in the butt you see - 121 and we sell
that - 120 - 77 - 77 - twenty-nine South
at - twenty-one you did have positive 44
then minus 120 and minus 17 so what
you're seeing here all negative Delta
almost all negative Delta minus 121
seven minus 120 minus 77 settled that -
77 he had positive Delta one if I happen
right as the bar opened this one this
bar was a little conflicted or the
you had positive Delta 44 so this bar
was probably green early on then selling
came and pushed it lower than this one
yet strong selling here - 120 didn't
turn positive but it end up at minus 17
so is that one point it was minus 120
and buying came back up tried to push it
to positive and then the bar obviously
finished it's a range bar so it moves
based on price then you formed the next
bar and you can see how it was zero and
143 is the max Delta and 131 is the the
final delts that's what you're seeing in
the Delta if you can just understand
this Delta for a second what's what
you're looking at you know it's telling
you that sellers were dominating here on
the way down now you've seen selling has
dried up and buyers are starting to
dominate on the way back up and you know
those are the types of setups that you
want to look for and you know I said I
said that's why I created the Delta
scalper so you don't have to sit here
and analyze this especially when it's
happening in real time very fast again
this is a range based chart and on range
based charts like I said you know 1336
you know 136 137 137 139 it's happening
lightning fast and if you're looking at
more than one market and more than one
time frame you know or chart type like
if say you got a range based chart in a
minute base chart E you're gonna lose
your mind because you're gonna be having
a look at eight different charts and you
know look for the one signal that that's
happening but you know that that's why I
created the Delta scalper that can run
on you know a normal bar chart so you
can you know have different charts open
up on your screens if you got multiple
screens and you could just see it you
know that the Delta scalper believed you
know it does have a
nothing never mind uh back off of that
but um you know so that way you trading
is visual for me and you know I like to
sit back and look at the screens and see
things you know as they're appearing and
you know if I have something that's
gonna highlight an area to me it's
saying hey you know what
based on what's happening in the Delta
you got a nice buying opportunity you
know that's just gonna make my analysis
easier that's why I create these tools I
don't call them indicators I prefer
tools is because it helps me you know in
my trading to make better trading
decisions so anyway thanks for watching
this video go to my website in order
flows calm or visit Delta scalper calm
if you're interested in that that tool
so thanks everyone have a great day
bye-bye
you